notre France sera aussi plus forte par
la relance de sa
natalité nous étions jusqu'à récemment
un pays don c'était la force sans doute
la singularité en Europe quand on se
compara au voisins et c'est moins vrai
depuis quelques années alors il y a
derrière cela des angoisses qui vont
avec la société peut-être des choix pris
Jadice sur certains sujets financiers il
appartiendra au gouvernement de
poursuivre ce travail mais je voudrais
insister sur deux points pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses après
l'allongement du congé paternité je
crois profondément que la mise en place
d'un nouveau congé de
naissance sera un élément utile dans une
une telle stratégie congé de naissance
qui viendra remplacer le congé parental
actuel d'abord il sera mieux rémunéré il
permettra aux deux parents d'être auprès
de leur enfant pendant 6 mois s'ils le
souhaitent et surtout il sera plus court
que le congé parental actuel qui peut
parfois aller jusqu'à 3 ans et qui
éloigne beaucoup de femmes du marché du
travail mais qui aussi crée beaucoup
d'angoisse parce qu'il est extrêmement
peu et mal rémunéré et donc crée des
situations parfois
impossibles la natalité baisse aussi
parce que l'infertilité progresse et je
parle là d'une forme de tabou du siècle
mais les meurs se changent on fait des
enfants de plus en plus tard
l'infertilité masculine comme féminine a
beaucoup progressé ces dernières années
et fait souffrir beaucoup de couples un
grand plan de lutte contre ce fléo sera
engagé pour permettre justement ce
réarmement
démographique